hey youtubers is Charlie so hopefully
you've all had a chance to see episode 1
of Korra book 4 but this is gonna be my
review and just because it's the first
episode and there's a lot of stuff to
get through I made it a little bit
longer and this is gonna be a top 10
heads up - it looks like Amazon's gonna
be releasing episodes at midnight
Pacific time
that's Thursday night or Friday morning
however you look at it Nickelodeon post
them on their website a little before
noon so if you're willing to pay a
couple dollars extra you can watch the
episode like eight twelve hours before
everyone else and again I know you guys
I'll be happy to know the weekly
giveaway is back all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video I'll announce the
winner whenever I post my Q&A tomorrow
but careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet okay here we go top
10 moments number 10 three years later
the high-speed rail system team Korra
being pulled in all different directions
the new earth Kingdom prince and
kuvira's mission to fix the mess in the
earth Kingdom the world has changed a
lot and the characters have changed a
lot number 9 meet Wu Prince of the earth
Kingdom I couldn't find any information
on who the voice actor was but I'll try
to find out by the time I post my Q&A
video Saturday or if you do know just
write it in the comments there's a whole
lot to say about him but he gives all
kinds of exposition about what's been
happening in the earth Kingdom kuvira
has been cleaning up the mess and he's
been living in exile they also find out
how he's related to hooting they're like
distant relatives distant cousins so he
probably just came from one of the
really wealthy families in Ba Sing se
based on the rest of the episode it
seems like he's gonna be on one side of
the conflict and kuvira on the other
with the prize being the throne of the
earth Kingdom the whole scene with the
pies just let us know that kuvira has
pretty much won over the populace but
she's gonna get the popular vote but
president Raiko from Republic City is
backing Wu so I'm wondering if the other
nations of the world are gonna back him
- it's probably just because he feels
like Wu is much easier to deal with than
a really powerful warlord I don't think
the president Raiko is gonna be a
villain or anything I just think he's a
politician through and through if you
remember that trailer scene with Zuko
his daughter and president Reiko it
seems that the other nations are gonna
back Wu and that's gonna cause the
greater conflict that's gonna be like
the spark in the flame that's gonna set
book 4
it'll be like the politicians of the
world versus kuvira in her army of the
people number eight team Korra montage
so we start learning where everyone is
and how they've changed three years does
not sound like a lot but everyone is a
little bit more mature and they've gone
from teenagers arguing about
relationships to young adults arguing
about politics I also saw that a bunch
of you were confused about some scenes
in the trailers where it looked like
team Korra people were fighting each
other that's not the case and I'll
totally explain it you can see though
how that might end up happening based on
everyone getting pulled in different
directions team Korra is not gonna be
broken apart for that long like they'll
get back together eventually number 7
Kai and opal to the rescue so this was
just like Makos intro scene during book
2 all over again
he gets that really cool motorcycle
chase intro when he does that big you
know firebending takedown to those
criminals the Triple Threat triads I
think Kai and opal exact same thing I
really am stoked about these new
airbender costumes they're gonna stand
out really nicely against the
metalbending army but there are just so
many awesome things to talk about about
just where the air nation is right now
in its stated development they're
basically like super cops now being
dispatched all over the earth Kingdom by
Tenzin and you can tell they're pros too
like they've been doing this for a long
time they're really good even though
they did lose those supplies I think
that was just a show that they were
fighting a battle they couldn't win like
it was supposed to feel like the mayor
had no other choice but to sign kuvira's
deal number six
Tenzin's family all grown up I love
seeing Rohan with hair like we haven't
seen him in a long time
and then there's meelo who looks like
he's about the same age as Kai was
during the book three Milla the boy
becoming meelo the man was probably the
best animation sequence in the episode
at least next to Koo Vera's fight we
also get a really good look at Jinora
with her hair again - I know some people
really didn't like her being bald I
didn't have too many issues with it but
she did look exactly like Aang but I
think that was the point I think she was
supposed to look like Aang or she was
supposed to remind us of Aang number
five ma ko is getting sent to Ba Sing se
on permanent duty just one more nail in
the coffin of team Korra this is gonna
put ma CO and Bolin in direct opposition
to each other brother against brother
it's just like opals
brother is on the opposite side from her
like families are going to be in
conflict this season it's a lot like the
United States Civil War you know
politics dividing families dividing the
country like I said earlier though I
don't think team core is gonna be at
each other's throats for too long I do
think they're gonna have a happy ending
but things are gonna get worse before
they get better
number four meet team kuvira think about
team kuvira as being an analog of team
Korra or even team Zaheer for that
matter but it's Bolin farukh Julie and
one of opals brothers not Skrillex I
think his name is pitar the perspective
shifts a couple times but we're mostly
seeing her inner circle from Bolin's
perspective I'm already starting to get
a little bit nervous about what's gonna
happen to team Korra though the train
itself looked amazing like the
high-speed rail I got the sense that
visually the train was also supposed to
represent the unstoppable nature of
kuvera this season like even rocks on
the tracks weren't enough to stop her
she's just metal bending the out of
everything in her path speaking of which
number three kuvira versus the bandits
probably one of the coolest uses of
metal bending that I've ever seen it
reminded me of book one when we saw
Korra using more sophisticated bending
techniques than we had seen in a Last
Airbender and like the metal bending
police force going all spider-man with
our cables it just becomes pretty clear
that kuvira is doing everything she can
to bring the earth Kingdom to heal those
bandits were so quick to accept her
offer of joining the army it sounds like
just everyone in general in the earth
Kingdom wants some relief like they want
some direction someone to lead them and
they really don't care who helps them
out the result is is that kuvira is just
constantly adding to her forces whether
it be the bandits or the states
themselves and all the supplies it
wasn't really clear when she had that
conversation with the mayor but the
contract said that they had to give her
supplies and manpower like that's what
she was taking from them number two
kuvira's unification plan revealed so
she's making all the states swear
allegiance in exchange for protection
it's technically not blackmail
unless she sends bandits back to the
city and that doesn't seem like her
flavor of evil it feels like something
Varrick would have done like whenever he
had people hijacked Asami's shipment
back in book 2 so she'd go bankrupt
remember he also framed mock Oh for that
based on that Lego map that cavero was
putting together in yes it did look like
she was playing with LEGOs she's almost
done with her mission like she's almost
completely unified the earth Kingdom the
t's being that if she completes the job
she'll have all the combined resources
of the earth Kingdom at her disposal
including their manpower most notably
their manpower so the potential is that
she'll decide she's a better candidate
to lead the earth Kingdom than Wu is and
you get your conflict like she could
raise up an army to fight off any
invading force trying to install Wu on
the throne which in this case might end
up being the Republic City forces who
just happened to be commanded by Zuko's
grandson we'll have to see how that
plays out
they didn't come right out and say
kuvira is not gonna give up control the
earth Kingdom once she's done but she's
the villain so it's gonna happen pretty
soon and my number 1 moment of course
Korra is an underground MMA bender
kuvira's been getting sharper literally
and Korra looks like she's barely
treading water not good I totally loved
the WTF reveal though of what she's been
doing for the last six months just
basically getting the crap beat out of
her in the trailer we saw a big spirit
world montage if anyone saw Superman -
like the really old Superman movie with
Christopher Reeve he basically gave up
his powers to begun human but found out
that the world still needed him to be
Superman so he literally had to
hitchhike all the way back to the
fortress of solitude to get his powers
back just like we see core here marching
through the snow back to the spirit
portal so yes she's definitely gonna get
her mojo back at some point but she's
gonna have to have a call to action
something has to change to slap her in
the face and wake her up because right
now it looks like she is completely lost
let me know what your favorite moment
was there's a whole lot to pick from and
let me know what do you think is gonna
be the big call to action that's gonna
make korra go back to the spirit portal
overall I gave the episode a solid a I
totally love the way they got through
all that exposition and reintroduced us
to the characters in the state of the
world it's like they're just setting up
a giant pie show board and now we get to
watch the game unfold in fact if you
actually rewatch the episode of book 3
when Asami and Bolin play pie show she
has this really good speech about what
it takes to win a game
I bet there's a really good lesson in
there for what's gonna happen in book
four so here's a clarification from some
of those scenes in the trailer that
everyone was confused about because we
actually got most of it answered so
first off here's Korra in her MMA outfit
in the swamps looking like she's gonna
get her butt kicked especially when she
gets captured in liquid metal
here we see Bolin jumping to escape from
one of the giant mechs you can kind of
see it jump down it's a little fuzzy
maybe he turns against kuvira soon
clearly someone else from the Army is
after him this person on the train that
Asami is fighting with the short hair
that's opals brother I know everyone
wondered if it was Bolin or ma Co
thankfully it is not this here though
with Korra is ma Co at this white lotus
temple no idea where it's located though
this top seen also kind of looks like it
came after that big swamp fight scene
just because she looks like she got the
crap beat out of her so yes I mean team
avatar is gonna be pushed apart by all
these political forces but they will
come back together eventually I'm hoping
it's like maybe the third fourth episode
when we see that but who knows
so really good news for any fans of the
comic book Bryan Konietzko basically
said that he's gonna double down on the
comic book after Korra book 4 is out
like he's hoping to work more on the
comic book so I know a lot of people
were wondering what's gonna happen with
the comics they will continue if you're
wondering where to buy them you can just
get them on comiXology online if your
local comic book shop doesn't have them
I will be posting a Q&A for this
tomorrow so be sure to leave all your
questions there's a whole lot of stuff
to talk about right now that you can
click here to get that video out of the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my top 10 avatar
villains thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five
do not forget Star Wars rebels tonight
be sure to
[Music]